ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะตาสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนน้องครูหญิงแล้วก็
ลูกสาวป๋าค่ะในวิดีโอระดับอะไรคะครูฟ้าใน
วีดีโอระดับกินเนอร์นะคะ Tuner ฟ้ามือค่ะ
ดิกินน่อ Class น็อคครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะวันนี้วันเสาร์
วันเสาร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์ 22 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคม
ปีพศอะไรคะมีผช
2565 อุ้ยปีคศมีอะไรคะมีข้อ 2  0  2255
ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้
พี่ไม่อยู่เสียงหนูไหมได้ยินอยู่ค่ะโอเค
ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
11 ค่ะคือของขวัญ
วันที่ 11
วันที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคมค่ะปีพต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะครูป๊า
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่เมื่อวันที่ 13
ค่ะดีเดือนมีนาคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะจะแล้วตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 น
3:00 น
กี่นาที
33 นาทีค่ะโคไซน์ชอบเลข 3 เหรอคะถ้า
เขียนแบบนักเรียนก็จะเป็นบ่าย 3 โมงสาม
สิบสามนาที
ครูขาโชว์ 6  3 ท่อรักเลขต่าง
ตอนนี้ก็เป็นเวลากลางวันหรอเป็นเวลากลาง
วันล่ะคะ 15:00 นแต่
กไก่รูหินเนี่ยดูครูฟ้า
วันนี้เนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยเปลี่ยนหน่อย
อะไรเปลี่ยนสุพรรณมีอะไรโคมไงทุกวันทุก
วันเนี่ยครูหญิงแล้วก็นักเรียนก็จะเห็น
ครูฟ้าใสครูฟ้าเนี่ยปล่อยผมแบบนี้
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าปล่อยผมแต่วันนี้
ครูฟ้า
มัดผม
ให้ค่ะมัดผม
ไฟฟ้าเนี่ยเปลี่ยนนิดหน่อยไงทำไมคะทำไม
กรูฟ้า
มัดผม
รูปปลามัดผมเพราะว่าผมกูฟ้ายาวผู้หญิง
Home พรอ้าวแต่ตอนนี้ครูฟ้าใช้แล้วก็ผม
ยาวยาวอย่างนี้เลยไหมคะ
ยาวไปนะคะอ๋ออ๋อครูฟ้าผมยาวทำไมแล้ว
เจอแล้วประเทศไทยมันร้อย
ใช่ไหมอาจารย์
38 องศาเซลเซียส
ร้อน
ร้อนมากฝาก็เลยบ่ผมยาว
ร้อนก็เลยมัดผมเหนื่อยนักร้อนนักเรียน
เนี่ย
ผมยาวก็ต้องมัดผมเหตุใจเพราะว่า
ถ้าผมสั้นโอเคไหม
ครูหญิงก็คิดไงคิดใช่ไหมคะเวลาประเทศไทย
ร้อนผมยาวเนื้อผมแบบยาวสีฟ้าเงี้ยไม่โอเค
ก็คิดนะตัดผมสมัยก็จะได้ผมยาวก็เปลี่ยน
ผมสั้นสวยอันนี้ผมสั้นครูฟ้าเนี่ยผมยาว
เหงาเอางา
ตาตัดถ่ายถ้าตัดก็ผมสั้นนะครูฟ้าชอบครู
ฟ้านะตัวเองนะครูฟ้าชอบผมยาวหรือว่าผม
สั้นครูฟ้านะ
รูป Part ถ้า
ผมยาวค่ะคุณหญิงสวัสดีนี้เนาะผมยาวยาวใช้
ผู้หญิงชอบผมยาวหรือว่าผมสั้นครูหญิงชอบ
ผมสั้นไหมค่ะชอบผมสั้นโง่แต่ตอนนี้เนี่ย
ครูหญิงเนี่ยผมยาวน้องผมยาวแล้วอ่า Green
ก็เลยมัดผมนะคะ
นักเรียนเนาะนักเรียนเนี่ยถ้าเป็นนัก
เรียนผู้ชายหล่อนักเรียนผู้ชายหรือว่าผู้
ชายน้ำผู้ชายเนี่ยมากๆผมยาว
หรือว่าผมสั้นคะฟ้าผู้ชายนะผู้ชายไงผม
สั้นค่ะเนาะผู้ชายเนี่ยผมสั้นอ่ะแต่ผู้
ชายเตือนให้ผมยาวได้ไหมโอเคไหมโอเคนี่ไง
ผู้ชายผมยาวโรงเรียนถึงนะ
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าให้ดูเหรอคะผู้ชายผมยาวผู้
ชายผมยาวโอเคนะคะผู้หญิงแบบนี้เนาะหมอใช่
อันนี้ก็คือผู้ชายแล้วก็ผมยาวเดี๋ยวพี่
เอานี้ออกก่อนนะ
สาย 6 ยาวปลานะคะอันนี้เพื่อนกูปลาผู้ชาย
ผมยาว
ได้น้องดูคนที่ผมยาวมากๆแล้วก็ถักผมเปีย
เห็นหน้าชายคนนี้เนี่ยผมยาวถักผมเปียเนาะ
ผู้ชายสมัยผู้ชายผมยาวโอเคผมสั้นโอเคเนาะ
ผู้หญิงผมยาว
โอเคผมสั้นโอเคฮะโอเค
ใส่ค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยผมยาวแล้วครูฟ้าฟ้ามีหู
ไหมคะ
วันนี้มีอยู่ไหมหูยาวมีไหมมีเนาะกูป่าว
เนี่ยหูยาวกับผู้หญิงเห็นไหมครูหญิงเนี่ย
หูสั้นหนังสั้นกว่าครูฟ้า
รู้ผู้หญิง
ครูฟ้าผมยาวยาวหูยาว
ครูหญิงเนี่ยอะผมยาวนะคะแต่สั้นนะ
สั้น
หนูหูสั้นยาวบาทครูฟ้าแล้วคอล่ะคะคอครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยคอยาวไหม
พ่ออยากนะคะไม่รักพี่เลยเนาะพอดีพอดี
แต่แต่
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยคอสั้นมีนักเรียนดูสิ
ทำไมคอกับหูเท่ากันเลย
นะคะดูคอสแมคคอสั้นหน้าขอสั้นเนาะแต่บาง
คนเนี่ยคอยาวในคนน่ะนะอะอันนี้เป็นหัว
สมัยแล้วก็เป็นผมแล้วก็คอและอันเนี้ยคอ
ยาว
ตั้งแต่บางคนก็จะ
คอสั้นนะขอสั้นมี 5 คนคอยจะเอานะคะว่าทำ
อะไร
นักเรียนขอยาวน้อ
ทรายค่ะก็ยาวมีคนคอยาวเนี่ยเพิ่งไปแล้ว
หายไปอยู่ทุกทีเลยค่ะอ๋อผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ย
ผมยาวคอยาว
เออนี่คนขอยาวค่ะน้องน้องก็มีผมยาวหูยาว
ไม่เก่งคอสั้นน่ะ
แขนล่ะคะครูฟ้าแขนมาแขนเนาะจริงๆผู้หญิง
เป็นคนแขนยาวนะ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงแขนยาวหรอคะ
โรงเรียนอาจจะไม่เห็นแต่ถ้าดูใช่ไหมอัน
นี้เนี่ยเป็นครูหญิง
อันนี้คอไม่ยาวนะคะ
ในตัวใช่ไหม
ปกติมา The  Balance กับเราใช่ไหมคะแตก
ผู้หญิงแยกแขนแหละผู้หญิงเป็นคนตัวเตี้ย
เอี้ยโน้ตสูง
cm นะคะไม่ใช่สูงเนาะแต่ว่า
แขนเนี่ยยาว
เป็นคนแขนยาวอะไรแค่ไม่เท่ากันหรอคะ
ฉันอยากผู้หญิงได้ไม่คนแขนยาวนะหาถ้าคิด
สวยๆ 150 เซนติเมตรแต่แขนเนี่ยยาว
แสดครูฟ้าล่ะครูฟ้าครูหญิงดูครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าก็เป็นคนแขนยาวใช่ไหมให้หอนคู่ฟ้า
เรียนนี่มาแล้วก็แคร์
ผู้หญิงต้องมี
มีสายวัดครับรู้ป๊ามีสายวัดใช่มั้ยมีสาย
วัดแบบนี้แล้วก็วัดแค
คุณครูหญิงเนี่ยยาว
เท่าไหร่
60  cm
คนเราจะเกิน
แค่นั้นผู้หญิงนะประมาณไม่ถึงหรอกเพราะ
ว่ามันเราแบบอย่างเงี้ยผู้หญิงนั้นคิดว่า
ประมาณอาจจะซัก 58  cm นะ
55  15 โวลท์ไปหมดแล้วครูหญิงน่ะแขนยาว
แขนยาวได้แขนยาว
แผนยาวมากอ่ะครีมแขนยาวมากครูฟ้าก็แขนยาว
หนอแล้วที่นี่ใช่ไหมที่มือน้องมือเนี่ยก็
มีนิ้วนะคะนิ้วที่นิ้วนอนนิ้วครูฟ้าเนี่ย
นิ้วยาวหรือว่านิ้วสั้นคะ
เปล่า
นิ้วยาวหานักเรียนนิ้วภูฟ้านะนิ้วเออคุณ
นิ้วยาว
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่
นิ้วไม่ยาวหรอก
แต่ไม่สั้นแต่ก็ไม่สั้นนะคะมันจะมีคนที่
เขานิ้วสั้นน่ะกูฟ้าเปิดได้ไหมคนในอู่
สั้นบางคนที่เขานิ้วสั้นน่ะมันจะสั้นมากๆ
แจกครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยนิ้วไม่สั้นนะคะ
นี่เด็กหรือเปล่าอันนี้เด็กใครเฮ้ยไม่
เด็กหรอ
ยังไม่เด็กอันนี้ไม่เคยฟ้าไงครูเบนซ์มา
นิ้วสั้นให้อย่างเดียวนะร้อนอ่ะนิ้วสั้น
นี่ไงหมด Li  on  Twitter เนี่ยนิ้วสั้น
ช่วยบางคนเนี่ยถ้านิ้วยาวเล่นเปียโน
คีย์บอร์ดดีไหมแต่บางคนเนี่ยนิ้วสั้น
บ้านเฮีย
นิ้วสั้นราคาเวลาดูแล้วก็ทำไมนิ้วสั้น
น้องแต่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ใช่คน
นิ้วสั้นครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคนนิ้วยาว
รหัสอ่ะอีก 1 อย่างค่ะในตัวเราก็คือขา
เลาะมีแขนก็ต้องมีขาหน้าขาตรงนี้นะขาครู
หญิงเนี่ยนะคะเป็นคนขาสั้นค่ะ
จะบอกผู้หญิงบอกดีเซนติเมตร
ครูหาอาสาครูฟ้าเนี่ยขาสั้นหรือว่าโป้ขา
ยาว
นักเรียนค่ะ
พูดอะไรเลยยกหางขึ้นมาก็ไม่ได้ไปได้ค่ะ
ยาวค่ะครูฟ้าเป็นครูฟ้าขายาวสมัยขายาว
จ่ายพวกนะถ้านักเรียนเห็นเนี่ยนี้ครูฟ้า
แล้วก็นี่ผู้หญิงนะค่ะกู้ไฟล์ของฉายายาว
ก็เลยสูงกว่าครูหญิงนะผู้หญิงเนี่ยขาสั้น
ราคาสั้นเนาะแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยอีกอย่าง
นึงที่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยเหมือนกัน
อะไรคะครูหญิงเจ้าก็เราสองคนเนี่ยใส่
เสื้อแขนสั้นจะเสื้อแขนสั้น
แค่นี้หนาวเสื้อแขนสั้น
เพราะว่า
วัดประเทศไทยเนี่ยเราบอกแล้วประเทศไทยหรอ
นี้นะคะเราก็เลยใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นแต่ถ้านัก
เรียนเนี่ยหนาวเนาะนักเรียนก็อาจจะใส่
เสื้อแขนยาว
สวยนี้เป็นเสื้อแขนยาว
ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยใส่เสื้อ
แขนสั้นรหัสเสื้อแขนสั้น
ผู้หญิง
เสื้อแขนสั้นร้องผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็ใส่กางเกง
ขาสั้น
ครูฟ้าใส่กางเกงขาสั้นหรือว่า
กางเกงขายาวครับขาสั้นขายาวใส่กางเกงขา
สั้นค่ะ
ครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงเหมือนกันใส่เสื้อแขน
สั้นใส่กางเกงขาสั้นๆอย่าให้เหมือนกัน
น้องจ่ายค่ะเดี๋ยวขลุ่ยจะมีรูปให้ครูฟ้า
ดูแล้วก็จะมีคำถามเกี่ยวกับสั้นแล้วก็ยาว
นอนที่เราพูดไปเลยค่ะผู้หญิงนะนึงนะคะๆ
เลยนี่ค่ะภูฟ้าเห็นไหมเห็นมึงค่ะอ่ะเห็น
ในรูปมีคนกี่คนคะครูฟ้า
ในรูปนี้ 1  2  3  4  5  6  6 คนค่ะอกคน
มีผู้ชายกี่คน
มีผู้ชาย 3 คนผู้ชายผู้ชายชายสาย
มีผู้หญิงกี่คน
มีผู้หญิง 3 คน
3 คนนะคะโอเคครูฟ้าคะในรูปเนี่ยมีคนผม
หนังสั้นกี่คน
ในรูปมีคนผมสั้น
1  2  3  4  4  4 คนค่ะแล้วในรูปมีคนผม
ยาวกี่คน
ในรูปมีคนผมยาว
2  2 คนค่ะหา 2 คนในรูปมีคนใส่เสื้อแขน
สั้นน้องแบบนี้นะเสื้อแขนสั้นอีกคนคะ
2  3  3 คนค่ะแล้วมีคนใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
กี่คนคะแน่ 1  2  3  3 คนค่ะทำไมผู้กัน
หมดเลยนะคะแล้วในรูปถ้ามีคนใส่กางเกงขา
สั้นกี่คนคะ
ชุด
กางเกงหรอ
เอาใหม่นักเรียนเอาใหม่กางเกงขาสั้น 1 คน
จ้า 1 คนแล้วในรูปมีคนใส่กางเกงขายาว
กางเกงขายาวกี่คนคะ
1  2  3  4  4  4 คนค่ะอ้าวอันนี้ก็เป็น
5 คนแล้วอีกหนึ่งคนใส่อะไรอ่ะไม่ได้ใส่
กางเกงขาสั้นไม่ได้ใส่กางเกงขายาวคนนี้
ใส่กระโปรงสั้นนี้เป็นอ่ะ
หมอนัดโรงน้องอ้าเป็นกระโปรงก็ในรูปมีคน
ใส่กระโปรงสั้น
1 คนใช่ไหมคะงูอื่นไทยค่ะน้องน๊อตเท่า
นี้นะคะนักเรียนเห็นไหม
Stock  Share นะคะสั้นกับยาวใช่ไหมคะ
สั้นกับยาวเนาะเราจะบอกผมสั้นผมยาวโอเค
หรือว่าเสื้อจะได้แขนสั้นแขนยาวโอเคนะคะ
ส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบายสวัสดี
ค่ะถ้ามี